But yeah, we've come a long way.
We hate to admit that we hate to admit it we've come a long way.
Like in the fifties, we had whites only, and blacks only water fountain,
which is incredibly sad, especially if you're a thirsty Asian.
What the hell are they?
They're doing drinking out of a faucet. No one talks about it.
Never come up once. Not a peep, not the black pillar. Can you believe this?
We got our own water phone age. Like, can I get a sip? I'm dying.
I got a triangular hat to block the sun.
Big fan of Asians. I think they're the best group. I think they're number one.
I don't think they get the credit. They deserve that.
I'm an Asian supremacist all the way.
I think they're better than the rest of any Asian people here. Hey, all right.
You should be working. God. What are you doing? Having a good time.
That's not the Asian. I know.
God what I want you to dealing black Jack or sitting on a box. Peeling,
something Big fan, best group.
Easily. The best group. No love you guys. Get the short on the chopstick.
It's pretty unfair. So quiet. So secure Asians, every other,
group's got a brag and boast. Every group's got a slogan, black people.
I'm black and I'm proud. White people, white power, Hispanics,
Not an Asian and just head down grades up. That's.
It. Angel.
The bet. You never hear about Asian crime. Never. If I was an Asian guy,
I would just start bugging people. I'm like, Hey, it's my word against yours?
Big fan.